Mark Ruffalo's Hulk will smash again in the
MCU.
At least that's the word coming from the folks
at The Illuminerdi, as the site is claiming
that "sources" close to Disney+ and Marvel's
upcoming She-Hulk series have provided "definitive"
proof that Ruffalo is officially on board
to reprise his role as Bruce Banner on the
small screen.
A kick-ass, new hero and a returning fan favorite?
"Best of both worlds."
It should be noted, of course, that the site
does not provide said proof for the masses
to see, nor do they actually say what that
proof is; one would have to imagine they've
seen Ruffalo's signature on an actual contract
for it to count as "definitive."
Either way, it still might be wise for MCU
enthusiasts to temper their excitement about
Hulk's return until Team Marvel makes their
own announcement.
That news would hardly come a shock, though,
as it's been widely rumored in recent weeks
that Ruffalo's big green guy would indeed
be joining the anxiously-anticipated She-Hulk
series.
ScreenRant reports that Ruffalo himself even
recently confirmed that he was in talks with
Marvel and Disney to reprise his role as Banner-slash-Hulk
for the Disney+ series.
Seems those talks might have been a bit further
along than Ruffalo was letting on, as The
Illuminerdi is now reporting the actor's deal
was likely already in place when he made those
comments.
There's still no confirmation as to how many
episodes of She-Hulk Ruffalo might appear
in, or if his new deal with Marvel might include
another big screen turn in the future, but
whatever the case, we're just psyched to see
Ruffalo's Hulk on screen again in any capacity.
If you recall, Mark Ruffalo took over the
role of Hulk after the folks at Marvel famously
parted ways with O.G.
MCU Hulk Edward Norton.
Making his first appearance in 2012's The
Avengers, Ruffalo immediately made the role
his own.
"Now might be a really good time for you to
get angry."
"That's my secret, Cap.
I'm always angry."
He continued to play Bruce Banner and Hulk
in four subsequent MCU flicks, not including
uncredited cameo appearances.
Marvel's brass are clearly fans, and have
now reportedly ensured that no other actor
will play Hulk for the foreseeable future.
As for what role Bruce Banner will play in
She-Hulk, if the Disney+ series stays true
to the character's comic book origins, his
role could be fairly major.
For those unfamiliar with She-Hulk, the character's
name is Jennifer Walters, and she's a successful
attorney, often for the superhero set.
She also just so happens to be Bruce Banner's
cousin.
If you're wondering how Walters becomes She-Hulk,
the transformation occurs after she receives
a blood transfusion from dear cousin Bruce,
after which she finds herself with a similar
green affliction, although she actually Hulks
out with her intellect and self-control intact.
"How's this, hot stuff?"
Walters eventually becomes a member of the
Avengers and A-Force, and she continues to
play a major role in Marvel comics, so you
can likely expect to see a lot more of the
character as the MCU charges ahead.
As for what that could entail, well, Marvel
Studios would be remiss not to use Walters'
career as an attorney, a 7-foot, green attorney,
that is, as a way to introduce her to the
wider MCU.
The studio's head honcho, Kevin Feige, has
already made it quite clear that characters
introduced via Disney+ series will be making
appearances in future films, and we can think
of a hero or two who may be in need of legal
representation in the very near future.
Case in point: Peter Parker, who was just
publicly outed as Spider-Man and framed for
an extremely high-profile murder, and who
suddenly has some blowhard named J. Jonah
Jameson ranting about what a menace he is.
"Spider-Man: A Psychopath wielding powers
he has no right to possess, trying to pass
himself off as a hero.
You're
no hero!"
As for Banner, well, for all we know, his
stint on She-Hulk could be a one-off deal
that sees him supplying the necessary Hulk
blood to facilitate his cousin's transformation,
and going on his merry green way.
We're not-so-secretly hoping, though, that
this news means that Ruffalo still has a vital
role to play in future phases of the MCU.
She-Hulk has not yet received an official
release date, but production on the series
is expected to begin in July; we'll keep an
eye out for an official announcement, and
we'll be sure to keep you informed.
"Hulk out!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.